Instructor: Ideally
you have ESLint set up right in
your editor, so as you write
code you can just have it in
real time telling you what your
errors and what your warnings
are. Now I'm going to show
how to use it in Sublime Text
and Atom, since those are
probably the two most popular
ones used with JavaScript
developers. However, every
editor worth its salt has some
sort of ESLint and linting
integration so you can feel free
to check that out with your
specific editor. If you
don't use Atom or you don't use
Sublime, feel free to skip these
ones or if you use Atom skip the
Sublime one, and I'll show you
how to use exactly in Atom
throughout this video. With
Sublime Text we need to use
something called SublimeLinter.
SublimeLinter is sort of like a
framework for all linting
because there's PHPLint and
CSSLint and SASSLint and there's
all different kinds of linting
that you can do for different
languages. Rather than
installing an ESLint plugin
directly, we install a linting
framework, and then we will
install plugin for that linting
framework. What you need to
do is, first of all, have
package control installed. I
assume you know how to do that,
if not, you can take a look on
how to do it or watch my Sublime
Text video series. I'm going
to type install package and from
that you type SublimeLinter.
Instructor: I don't
see it showing up in here
because I already have it
installed. If you do not see it,
that probably means you already
have it installed as well.
After you've installed that one,
go ahead and type install
package again and you want the
SublimeLinter and you just
search for ESLint. Again, I
don't see it as well, but it's
going to say SublimeLinter-
contrib-eslint, and you go
ahead and install that one.
If you want to know if you have
them both installed you can just
type list packages and you
should look for lint, you see
that I have SublimeLinter and
SublimeLinter-contrib-eslint.
Those two are the ones that I
use to lint my JavaScript and
you need to make sure that you
have them installed. The
third thing you need to do, and
this is very, very important, is
that you have to have ESLint
globally installed. These
plugins don't come with ESLint.
They use your system's ESLint.
Again, if you've been doing this
tutorial with me you already
have it installed, but double
check by saying eslint --
version and see that you have
ESLint actually installed. In my
experience, you have to give
Sublime Text a full shutdown, so
do a Sublime Text quit. Then
open up Sublime Text again to
get it to run. Then what you
need to do is turn it on so that
it lints as to your preference.
I like to have my linting every
time I hit save, it's going to
lint it. Sometimes you can also
just lint it on demand, or
people have it linting every
single time that the type a
character. I find that when
you are typing and you're not
done writing your code, it will
give you errors before you're
done. Then on the other end, you
just forget to lint, so I like
to do it on save. The way that
you do that is open up your
command palette, Command shift P
or control shift P on Windows
and just type SublimeLinter.
You can see all of the possible
options. What we want to do is
Choose Lint Mode, and here we
have "background," lint whenever
text is modified, that's as you
type. "Load or save," only do it
when the file is loaded or saved.
That's what I have it. "Only
do it on save." I do it on load,
because when you open a new file
I also want to lint it. Then
finally, "manually lint only
when requested." I could do it
manually here, and then I could
just write all the code not
knowing there's any errors, and
then I could just say "Lint this
view," and it's going to lint it.
You'll start seeing that you
have dots show up in the sidebar
here. That means that there's
errors, in my side bar, and then
it will actually underline the
actual characters that are
giving me grief. Sublime Text
shows them in the status bar at
the very bottom here. It's kind
of small and it's a little bit
out of the way, so you have to
look back at it. What I like to
do is just click on it and then
read error, tweets is never
reassigned. Use const. Prefer
const. That's the error that I
have. I would change this
one to const, give it a save,
and now I see another error. Now
I don't see any errors, actually,
because I have to "Lint this
view." I don't want to do that,
so I'm going to say Choose
Linting Mode and I'm going to
say "load or save." Now when
I give it a save, immediately it
shows up and I can just see here,
a space is required after curly.
I got a bit of a space issue
here. A save, now I've still got
something popping up here. What
is it telling me? Space is
required after the curly. Save,
and I just go through these one
by one, without having to run it
from the command line. This does
it in every single JS file.
That's what Sublime is. It's
pretty simple to get set up.
Sometimes people have trouble
getting it up and running, and
it's really important that you
do those three things. Make sure
you have ESLink globally
installed, make sure you have
SublimeLinter installed first,
and then install the contrib
eslint package for SublimeLinter.
If you get all those three lined
up perfectly, you should be in
really good shape having linting
working. You don't have to do it
via the command line any longer.
Atom works very much the same
way, except they don't use the
Sublime contrib eslint package,
it uses its own package. Here
I've got it up and I'm running
using the same cobalt2 color
scheme here. But one cool thing
about Atom is that, first of all,
it will give you the errors
nicely down here. It's a little
bit nicer than Sublime Text.
Also, when you click on one of
them it will tell you unexpected
var. It will give you the actual
name of it, you can click on it,
it will bring you to the
documentation. The
implementation in Atom is
actually much better if you're
using Atom. How do we get
this installed? First of all you
need to go to your settings and
install two packages. Those two
packages are linter, which is
like the linting framework, just
like we did with Sublime Text,
and then the second thing you
want is linter-eslint. I've
already installed those, but you
would just type here for linter.
You'll go ahead install that,
and then the other one is linter-
eslint, which you would install
that. Once you have those
installed, you simply go ahead
and start writing your .JS code
and you are up and running. No
further configuration needed.